[Music]
my name is Robin Warner I am a customer
engineer and Google Cloud I've had the
privilege of working with sling TV over
the last year with some really exciting
things they're doing in order in
transforming their workloads you heard
this morning that a big focus in Google
cloud is making it easy to deploy and
making sure you're not locked in so the
promise of serverless networking or
serverless computing server lists
workloads to minimize operations and
open source tools or managed open source
tools they really allow you to run the
workloads you want to and still have the
power of the open source community
behind that I've been I've had the
privilege of working with them for about
a year now and watching this journey
over the last probably nine months as
they take existing machine learning
workloads machine learning algorithms
that had been built previously and
moving things into GCP and all of the
things that they got to learn along the
way and we all love to learn stuff along
the way so Austin Bennett is a senior
data engineer with sling sling media and
salmieri ozzie is a data scientist also
with sling media and they're gonna give
us a little glimpse into the journey
that they've had over the last nine
months
so Austin you kick it off
all right cool so far so good
cool I think he just covered that so
I'll walk you through the agenda to
start you know why is it that we're
playing around with GCP at all you know
a bit about our data and overview of the
sort of things that we're addressing how
how we took things from a local laptop
to virtual machines to using cloud
machine learning engine know machine
learning project can you know work well
without data being where you need it so
some thoughts on how to move data around
and migrate it a bit on pre-processing
with data flow on beam and digging into
how to automate some prediction using
cloud composer or you know hosted
airflow in the open source sense so for
our motivation we had used to be a
analytics group so just reporting for
things around sling TV but the goal
wound up being we needed to support
machine learning workflows for a bunch
of reasons the current tools being you
know managed database services really
aren't great for machine learning
workflows so we needed to change our
tooling and infrastructure one way I
think of a trade-off that is needed in a
lot of places is a data warehouse versus
a data Lake so data warehouse being
really just a sequel kind of engine
could be you know your my sequel or
whatever store or some MPP system is
super familiar to many people and
updates are really you know
straightforward the ability to in a data
Lake to otherwise work with machine
learning flows just read the data off of
some form of say blob storage super nice
for you know SPARC ml and things like
that so kind of where to use which
system so you're not trying to unload
your data out of a database itself
also kind of an origin our group you
know was nice and sent me to the K DD
conference in 2017 to keep track of
research in the area there you guys may
have come across the tf-x paper on you
know things around tensorflow and a
really nice way to productionize machine
learning so was familiar with that and
eager to follow the developments and
they've you know been attentive to that
open source super cool I don't like
managed services where what's going on
under the hood isn't apparent as well as
then I can really dig into the code and
understand what's going on so here's a
whole lot of things that we either had
been using our made sense to jump into
and then really a quick shout out to
these other things we're trying to get
through the whole infrastructure and
pipeline to you know some more even opsi
sort of things and then really what
kicked off this process was the cloud
next last year so where you guys are now
as well as we as a group came and saw
all the great things other companies
were doing so it made sense to really
dig in and figure these things out
some was going to share a bit on our
data background hi everyone thanks for
joining our session I'm gonna start
talking about the data and background
and the many iterations we have to take
in order to get to our end-to-end
machine learning pipeline that we have
today so how many of you know what sling
TV is that's so many for those of you
who don't know sling TV is an online TV
platform where users can sign on and
watch online live TV and on-demand
contents I like so many other
subscription services or
with customer turn we want on identify
the customers before they turn so we can
do something about it for this binary
classification problem we can look at so
many different features for example what
users watched what channel they watch
how long they watch it for what day of
the week and the timeslot this is just
an example we can look at millions of
attributes so for this charm prediction
problem that's assume that we look at
six days of activity and one a
prediction at day 30 for this one user
the user comes subscribes on the first
day and watches the ESPN for 1500
seconds and it's a Monday night they
come back again on the second day they
watch Food Network and it's Tuesday 6 to
8 p.m. they don't watch anything on day
3 and 4 and they come back again and
watch some Travel Channel on a Friday
morning for many dot non deep learning
models this data needs to be aggregated
per user so for that one user you will
have total number of seconds watch
Channel most-watched total number of
sessions most was it mostly a weekday or
weekend and most common timeslot however
this kind of model will disregard the
daily pattern of user activity there are
these studies online the papers that use
convolutional neural networks for churn
prediction and they use daily patterns
daily activities of users the model
architecture for this kind of model is
has multiple convolutional layers
followed by max pooling and then it gets
to a fully connected layer and then it
will get to a final soft max or sigmoid
output for the final classification
I don't do this left the screens flicker
yeah okay in order to use this kind of
model we need to clarify between days of
activity and inactivity so for the days
that the user has been an active we need
to insert zeros for example for the days
three four and six we insert zeros for
the numerical values and encode the
categoricals then these before before
feeding this data into the model the
data needs to be encoded and scaled for
numerical it needs to be scaled between
0 & 1 and for categorical it needs to be
encoded so after trying that we were
able to improve our model metric by 15%
compared to our baseline non deep
learning models for that one sample if
you look look at one user for 6 days of
activity with 5 features it's very
simple to pre-process and train the
model however with many if you want to
look at a more granular time time
standard for example minutes or hours
and for millions of users with thousands
of features this problem gets very
challenging really quick
so now I'm going to talk about how I did
the pre-processing and each iteration
first I started small with datawarehouse
I moved that they dog to a virtual
machine pre process and save the data on
the virtual machine using pandas and
numpy I'm gonna get into the details in
the futures life I trained the virtual I
trained the model it was the Charis
model on the virtual machine the
predictions on the virtual machine the
only thing is that I needed to
pre-process the predictions the same way
that i pre-process the training data and
then i said that saved the predictions
to the original database so we realized
quickly that that system was not it was
not good for production it's not very
scalable and we wanted to move towards
server less scalable system so we
started changing our tools and moving
through GCP first I tried I started with
the original database moved it to Google
storage and did the pre-processing and
data lab using the same functions and
same tools
I saved the pre-processed data to Google
storage did the training with Karros on
CM le cloud machine learning services
and did the predictions on virtual
machine I did this because last year
Karras was not compatible with the model
API but I think today things are
different after that I did the
predictions on the virtual machine and
save the predictions to the original
database again I needed to do the
pre-processing on the prediction data
this is detail about the code I used for
the first two iterations first I read
the unloaded CSV file into a panda's
data frame then I scaled and encoded the
data and then I said it went on fire
while inserting zeros to the form the
reason I showed earlier and then I saved
the numpy and pickle files the encoding
was you I did the encoding using label
encoder and standard scalar by
scikit-learn I say the typical files
which I needed to keep track of
throughout the modeling process the
problems are scaled extra packages the
pickle files and prediction
pre-processing this is how the model
architecture looks like it well first if
you look at the first four lines I am
reading the whole numpy array at once
and then I'm loading the pickle files
the problem with loading everything at
once is that if you look at the bottom
part I get an out of memory error in
cloud machine learning and then after
that it's just a normal carrot model
before solving the out of memory error
while the data was small I experimented
with hyper parameter tuning which is a
really cool tool you can set your
parameters and experiment with it so
here this is a very exaggerated hyper
parameter tuning example we never want
to experiment with this many but here I
am
tuning I'm trying to experiment with
number of filters and the convolutional
layers patch size optimizer
and dropout size on the right you will
see the ya know file that is submitted
along with the job and in there you will
set the ranges that you want to try for
example if you look at the optimizer
there's Adam as GD Adam axe and others
on tester board you can follow all these
trials that are being run and based on
your model metric you can pick your
favorite one so here on the lower left
pane
pick number 18 and on the Google cloud
platform you can go and find what number
18 hyperparameters where so here the
first con layer the number of filters
were 112 and the optimizer was Adam axe
while in time for board you can also
check the model graph and see if
everything looks expected and if
anything stands up for troubleshooting
so now back to the out of memory error I
still needed to solve that part so this
time I started with the original
database
I moved the data to Google storage did
the pre-processing on data lab and saved
on my array again but this time I
converted the numpy array to a TF record
file so I could use it well I could use
TF data and tensorflow
to beat the data in batches and then I
did the predictions on the model API in
cloud machine learning and save the
prediction to bigquery again I needed to
do pre-processing on predictions
so here's how I I converted it converted
the numpy it to TF record file I use the
an image example which saves all my
features to a feature called
X which is inconvenient because later it
will harp it will be hard to get to each
feature by name but this solve the out
of memory error and the scale issue so
this is the model input data and
architecture first you need the parsing
function to parse your input the TF
record file here there's x and y-axes
all the features combine them on the
input function it will read the data in
batches and you can set it to shuffle
your training data
so just a reminder this is where
iteration three is everything is almost
in Google cloud platform except for the
beginning part which is the original
database and now Austin will take us to
how he moved that to bigquery thank you
okay cool so I meant to switch the order
of these slides
okay so bigquery is great I mean I
talked about a trade-off before of
between a data Lake and a MPP database
realistically bigquery gives you the
best of both worlds like curating data
and needing to think about the files on
a storage system is a pain and I don't
want to do it and I'm glad there was a
managed service for it I can update data
and not think about things it's as
performant as anything else I've seen
haven't needed to do a ton with it yet
but the ability to share data across
different organizations across projects
is super straightforward and I didn't
pay attention enough earlier today as to
whether or not the bigquery read API was
talked about but it's super cool gives
us direct access to the underlying
storage which you know for then letting
data flow beam jobs or spark etc access
that data directly a great way to try
stuff out also which I wish would have
existed when I first got started is
there's a transfer service that you know
input a few parameters in the UI which I
prefer to not use UI's but this will get
you moving really quick in our case we
moved a few terabytes over and saw
performance was great given that I just
gave you you know great sales pitch on
how great it is I also like everything
isn't all roses all the time right so I
ran out of
resources even on bigquery in one
specific instance although oh well
talking with the bigquery team
eventually we were able to do this sort
of query which we were able to do
elsewhere they you know fixed things
more or less and then this became not an
issue so ml can't be a like successful
without ingesting and moving data around
so want to talk about a few ways batch
ingest from various places third party
API is that we may hit and stream API s
and using you know some various you know
open source or at least managed to tools
oh yeah also container organization is
pretty cool we have like a lot of our
stuff had been has been orchestrated
from like a central virtual machine
which although has worked very well also
has its problems for scheduling resource
conflicts and you know like package
issues and versions those sorts of
things go away when we adopt these sorts
of containerization practices which
we've been working towards
many of our batch ingests are patterns
like this and and also I guess the point
I'm gonna try to get across in this talk
to is you know multi cloud is totally
doable
you know it's use the great tools where
they exist or within the confines of
your organization if people say you need
to use something don't you know it's
it's not all or nothing so many of our
workflows our data gets dropped into s3
for instance this is a very simplified
workflow of once a spark job that
transforms stuff back into s3 to do
things with it for instance just take
that output and copy it over using the
transfer service or gsutil or whatnot
and then it's in cloud storage another
way that we've played with is on data
ingest in the first place into s3
get over to cloud storage right that'd
be more data flow job get it over to
cloud storage especially once it's there
and because we're talking about batches
straightforward to get it into bigquery
also dataflow beam okay yeah that arrows
missing but dataflow beam can go
straight into bigquery and then I put
poof because I think I haven't tried it
yet but I think that there's zero
problem right having data flow and being
readwrite from s3 and right there the
things exist to do it but I haven't
tried it yet but that seems like a great
way to simplify my architecture another
bit on batch ingest we have a bunch of
third party data providers that we get
data from so hit the API in in the first
iteration
gke and a container was managing
everything so it would go to a bigquery
get say the last time stamp of things go
back to the API get the data it needs is
right to storage and then we'd use a
data flow um beam job to right things to
say bigquery and Google storage
things got a little more simplified when
adding air flow to the mix which then
let the orchestration being the composer
airflow layer and smaller containers and
discrete services and then we're able to
reduce like query costs from keeping the
metadata itself in fire store rather
than in bigquery and needing to you know
essentially using fire store as a
metadata store of the last time stamp so
just a quick key value lookup streaming
data ingest we have processes that look
like this
you know nginx and logs - on-premise
endpoints stream - Kafka go to log stash
that winds up getting bashed and written
to s3 and load it into redshift 4 to
support our other fantastic groups and
colleagues we work with we then
wind up adopting more of the data Lake
model unloading things out of redshift
using say spark and writing that back
into s3 for column there bits since we
absolutely have to support s3 dataflow
and beam though can read right from
Kafka and are able to write to these
other bits first streaming data we're
still toying with whether we're gonna
get enough value out of BigTable itself
to bigquery read from BigTable right to
both or if bigquery is going to be
itself and although data flow and beam
can talk to our Kafka clusters directly
we went ahead and just jumped all the
way to having nginx and logstash
forward right to pub/sub because if with
the eventual goal being let's get our
on-premise infrastructure into the cloud
and it looks like we're leaning towards
using Cloud endpoints and cloud
functions although we're first proving
out the rest of the pipeline that's here
big fan of things beam and giving a
shout out to this session on Thursday of
my colleagues there
11:42 12:30 stream analytic stuff
alright and then some was going to share
more on our modeling
so now that we have data in bigquery
Thank You Austin for putting in the
query everything is in the query now so
now I start from bigquery
but again as often mentioned earlier we
were up next last year and we learned
about all these new tools like data flow
TF transform that are great for
pre-processing big scale data so I
wanted to give those a try and I found
this course Sue's on Coursera that are
really helpful and they don't lab is a
great tool to follow the courses on
Coursera and learn TF transform so this
time I started from bigquery then did
the pre-processing on data lab but as
the pre-processing I mean submitting a
job to data flow and then I saved
pre-process data on Google storage train
the same model on C Emily predicted on C
Emily and wrote it to bigquery but this
time no pre process for predictions so
that's great here's a learning example
of TF transform on data lab in case you
guys are interested you can follow it
and troubleshoot your code it's
interactive and it's easy to follow
examples serverless and customizable so
here's the our final iteration which is
much shorter than the beginning and
scalable and serverless we start from
bigquery to the pre-processing on data
flow save the TF record files on cloud
storage do the training and predictions
on C Emily and invited to bigquery here
we we solve all these problems of scale
extra packages and no more pickle files
there is no pre-processing for
predictions because TF transform writes
the graph and you can point your model
to the graph of the output of TF
transform and it will automatically
process it for you here's an example of
a beam pipeline that I you
first I read the data from bigquery
no more unloading data from database it
just reads it straight from there second
step is grouping by user which is just
reordering the elements then I insert
zeros and reshape I'm going to get into
the details in the upcoming sub slides
and then I scale and in code using the
TF transform functions and then finally
I write it to a TF record file these are
the first three steps the first function
is just a query just select a query the
second one is data validation here I'm
checking to see if days greater and
equal to zero but it could be anything
the third step is collect users which is
a it reorders then put elements so it
can group by later the fourth step is
the right format numpy operation
function which is just a normal number
function and the fifth step is where the
encoding and scaling happens so after
the fifth step the TF transform graph
gets written to your bucket where you
can point your model to here's the
dataflow example I'm gonna show you a
demo later but just in case here's like
an example you can follow each step and
see where you are you can see your job
description and summary and on the right
middle pane you can see the auto scaling
so here I needed 70 workers for ten
minutes it auto scale to 70 and then
back down and my job was done in 15
minutes so now I'm gonna move to the
demo
all right so there's these two files
that are very similar to what I showed
you I'm gonna run it from the terminal
and hope that it will work
so here's a GCP platform a homepage here
you can find the compute engine ml
engine like all these tools that I just
talked about bigquery but I'm interested
in data flow and one of them has kicked
off the graph is still being analyzed so
we have to wait a little bit
okay so here you can follow what's
happening the first step is a big Q
import and it didn't run so in order to
check why you can always click on the
step and click on the logs and it will
give you the error which here it says
big query execution failed because on
Brock and recognize name I just put a
unrecognized name there so you can see
the error all right this is the second
one which is exactly like the one I
showed you before you can see the step
step that's running I'm running it for
my training data and also the validation
data and they all get saved here's where
the transform function gets saved this
is where the transform happens the other
scaling is kicking off here you can see
the job information and the resource
metrics and the pipeline options you can
always submit a setup file with it to
specify what you want here's the auto
scaling the current workers are zero but
it wants to be seventy if we wait a
little bit the current workers will go
up to 70 and then back down and the job
will be done this is the same job that I
showed you the picture before so we
don't have to wait 15 minutes so I'm
going to back go back to the slides now
all right so in the model the only thing
that you need to change is the serving
input function where you point it
through the TF transformed graph output
this is how it happens and then the
floor is the predictions output where
there's viewer ID probabilities and
prediction classes so now that we have
all the pieces of the puzzle together it
would be great if we could have this
automated daily so we could have daily
predictions every day and here's Austin
who will tell us how he did that all
right so cool
things should be automated and whatnot
we're doing batch predictions one of the
more straightforward ways of doing it is
unload from
bigquery to get those records in new
line JSON format in this case we used
beam data flow write those to Google
Cloud Storage a second step being hit
the ml engine predict service read for
read those files from Cloud Storage
write them back to cloud storage and
then just for what we've been doing
those batch results are just going into
bigquery so we can do things with them
so it's three step process to highlight
what this is we have you know our beam
job which is called extract up PI the
documentation is super straightforward
on how to use beam data flow to do some
things composer airflow less so for
these operators I'm really hoping they
wind up getting accepted for I forget if
it's summer or season of Docs where then
there should be some resources helping
even the open source projects get some
documentation going but you can take
more or less the the Python
command command line and translate that
into what's needed for air flow this is
for the data flow operator equivalently
hey we see a whole lot of variables
we're using and using the g-cloud ml
engine job submit again documentation
really great and here with the ml engine
batch prediction operator you can see I
had to make this pretty straightforward
we're like it's pretty much plug and
play here and the same goes for the BQ
command line tool and the load command a
little bit more to it but also again
pretty straightforward so that's how we
you know weave these things together yes
they can be you know cron jobs for those
sort of command line tools that we saw
but air flow Composer gives us a lot
more visibility into stuff and also hey
let's learn these because those lessons
get applied all over the place like we
saw earlier for moving batch data around
ok so so far summary we've seen how we
slowly built on to our eventual solution
the real goal was how can we have in our
tool set the like best scaleable
solution that we can work on even with
say our twelve gigabyte data sets when
we need to work with our mini terabyte
data sets and anything in between but
hopefully as you've seen you don't have
to not show any progress for a long time
while you figure things out you can work
towards those solutions using tensorflow
stuff we've seen better predictions
trying to get that across and yeah you
can use open source tools and also we're
a very small group that that we've been
working with so leveraging server lists
and managed services are amazing so we
don't have to
quick announcement also I'm helping
organize the beam summit in Europe
if you're into beam dataflow for even
running things like tensorflow transform
check this out in mid-june also there
will be a beam summit track for two days
in September in Vegas Apache con another
place to check stuff out and then
wanting to say thanks to a bunch of
people so especially our slingin dish
colleagues for you know encouraging and
supporting this path either you know
directly or by supporting you know the
needs of the group so we had the time
and ability and attention to devote to
these sorts of things to the GCP team
that helped us along this journey
certainly thanks to the open-source
tools and everybody either paid or
volunteer in these open source
communities and you know you guys for
your attention
[Music]